If you're anything like me,...
...then you probably find yourself dealing with this problem on a fairly regular basis.
You should be going to bed,...
...but there's just so many more interesting things to do at night.
So what can we do about this problem?
Well, one simple solution is to create a night routine.
A night routine is just like a morning routine, but in reverse.
Instead of helping you wake up and get ready for the day,...
...it helps you to smoothly end your day...
...and also make sure that you get to bed in time to get enough sleep.
But there is another benefit to having a good night routine.
In addition to helping you wind down today,...
...it also helps you prepare for the next day as well.
Today, we are constructing a one-hour nighttime routine.
And with this routine, we've got three different goals in mind.
Number one, wind down the day so you feel relaxed when it's time to go to bed.
Number two, actually get yourself in bed on time so you're getting enough sleep.
And number three, do a few things to help you prepare for the next day.